So Californium is another element which was
first prepared at the
Berkeley labs in California. It’s got quite
a few military applications,
usually involving the word ‘nuclear’.
But what most people don’t realise is
it’s actually used in various types of machines
for detecting metal fatigue
and stress in airplanes, so obviously it’s
pretty important our planes don’t
fall to bits in mid-air and they are used
in the kind of instruments which
scan for this and can spot any problems long
before they become a
serious issue.
It’s also probably the only other actinide
which has possibly routinely got
its way into households which is that it’s
also used in metal detectors.